Tout simple, vous défendez les agriculteurs,
on est bien d'accord, c'est-ce que vous dites ?
Exactement bien.
Il faut rétablir
donc les droits de douane sur les produits
agricoles ukrainiens.
Vous êtes d'accord ?
On doit trouver. Vous êtes d'accord, ou pas ?
Non, on doit trouver. Ah bah non,
vous défendez les agriculteurs.
Bon, déjà, pour,
pour, on doit trouver.
Monsieur Bourdin, laissez-moi expliquer.
Oui, je vous explique,
l'Ukraine doit être soutenu dans son effort de guerre.
Oui, on doit trouver 1 capacité de soutenir l'Ukraine
en achetant ses céréales,
tout en protégeant les paysanes et les paysans d'Europe.
Et donc, pour cela,
on a plein de dispositifs qui sont possibles.
Et je vous dis,
si, si, les écologistes étaient décisionnaires,
vous le savez qu'on est pas majoritaire,
ni en France, ni en Europe aujourd'hui,
et on se bat pour le devenir.
Euh. Si les écologistes étaient majoritaires,
on aurait peut-être trouvé 1 moyen
d'acheter les céréales ukrainiennes et de pouvoir,
euh. Avec ses céréales,
subvenir aux besoins d'une grande partie,
par exemple, de l'Afrique
qui souffre éminemment de la famine.
Donc euh. Cette concurrence,
euh généraliser,
euh. Avec des pays où on produit
avec moins de normes sociales,
environnementales et sanitaires,
elle est néfaste.
Il faut qu'on trouve d'autres moyens
que la suppression des droits de douane,
ça j'en convient.